INSTRUCTOR: Hello, vizzers.
This is a design challenge
starter for the birthdays chart.
So let's go ahead and take
a look at the assignment.
OK, so you have the opportunity
to select one of these choices.
They may be updated
and different,
as I'm always including
some new challenges here.
But we're going to take
a look at the birthday 1,
where it asks, how
common is your birthday?
There's a little
bit of background
reading to get context,
and there is the CSV file.
It is only looking at
births from 1994 to 2014.
I'm hoping you are
all in that age range
and are that birth range.
And then here are
two visualizations
that have been created.
So we're going to
recreate this one,
and then we're going to do
some other explorations.
So let's go ahead
and minimize this.
And I've already brought
in the data into Tableau.
And one of the things, I
just want to look at the data
to see what we've got.
We've got the year here.
I've got 7,670 rows, 5 fields.
I can see I've got my birth
month, my date of birth,
my day of week, and my birth.
So I think I'm going to rename
this one to just say date.
That makes a little more sense.
Day of week, what this means
is that, if it's a number 1,
that is a Sunday.
Number 2 is a Monday.
Number 3 is a Tuesday.
So number 7 would
be that Saturday.
And then the number
of births, OK great.
I'd like to create
one more field,
and I'm going to do that
here in the data source.
What I'm going to do is
just do a drop down anywhere
and do a calculated field.
And I'm going to call this one
DATE, and what I want to do
is use a function
called MAKEDATE.
And I'm going to
just add in the year.
And then I'll do comma,
and then I'll do the month.
And oops.
And then I'll do day-- oh,
I think I called that Date.
OK, I think I want
to call that date.
OK, so this is valid.
But I'm going to redo
this because that's
going to get confusing.
So I'm going to call that Day.
Now, my calculation
might be off.
So let me go up and change it.
Great.
OK, fantastic
So now, I've got that.
And you can see that it's
called a calculation.
So you can create it right
here in the Data pane
or on the sheet.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to go to the
very first worksheet
here and recreate that original.
So let's go ahead, and I'm
going to put down the OG here.
So what we'll do is we're
going to go ahead and bring Day
onto column, and we're
going to bring our month.
And we're going to
change that to a--
let's go.
Actually, you know
what I want to do
is I'm going to first
select all of these.
And I'm going to change
them all to discrete.
So now, they've gone from
that green to that blue.
Now, I'm going to
bring in that day,
and then I'm going
to bring in the date,
and you can already see how
it's behaving differently,
and I'm going to
go to month here.
So now, I've got
the 1 through 31.
Let's actually fit this
into the tire review
here so you can see that.
31 and then what I want to do
is bring in my average births
onto color.
So now, I've got this
big field of blue.
But I don't want
to deal with sum.
I want to do an average.
So I'm going to
change the aggregation
from the default to average.
So you can already see
some things lighting up.
This color palette is
not working for me.
I'm going to go ahead
and drag this over here.
So I'm going to go ahead and
change that color palette
to something different.
Now, I could create
a color palette
similar to what the example
was with the different shades
of pink and purple.
But I think what I
want to do is to do--
we'll do maybe a
diverging palette here,
and let's just go ahead and
apply that so I can see,
not a lot of differences.
So I think what I want
to do is do a stepped.
Let's do like 9.
OK, I'm actually
going to reverse this
so I can have the
red on this side.
And so we've got 6,000 to--
I think what I want to do
is change this and maybe
make this a little.
Change this from 9,000,
and we'll do the end at 13.
OK, let's apply that.
OK, good, good, good.
All right.
So that's getting better.
So I can see some
hot zones, which
will be those dark red
and the lighter zones,
which will be that black.
So then I actually want to
go back into this color.
I'm going to add
a border in here.
So now it's automatic.
And now I'm going to do
just that white border.
OK.
So That's looking
a lot more similar
to what the OG look like, except
just a different color palette.
Now, you can go ahead
and play with this
when you get into
your design realm
to maybe add in a different
kind of color palette.
But what you can
see right here is
I've got a lot of this red
here in September and in here,
and then fewer births
in these darker months.
OK, so that, we've
got the OG made.
So step number 1.
Now, we're going to
do some wild cards.
And I want to do a
couple of wild cards
because making charts is fun.
So here's wild card number one.
This is the exploration for
some different chart types.
I'm going to go ahead and
bring in day of the week here.
And I'm interested
to see if there's
some sort of days of the week
that more babies are born
during this period of time.
So I'll bring in those
births right here.
So now what I see remember
that this is the Sunday,
and this is Saturday.
So not as many
birthdays on Friday.
That's kind of interesting.
More in the middle of the week.
I suspect this might have to
do with OB/GYNs and their work
schedule.
But I don't know.
Anyway, that's an
interesting wild card,
and you could run with that a
little bit more if you want to.
I'm going to continue to make
another wild card with you just
because this is so much fun.
Of course, you can
go to something--
you can do something
else right now,
or you can continue to
watch my exploration.
I'm going to bring
my date in here,
and I think I'm going
to look at the month.
We'll look at months, and we'll
look at months and births.
And let's see if
there's a certain birth.
Let's go ahead and we're going
to jump to a bar chart for this
too.
But you could do a line.
In terms of total births
over the whole data set,
it's pretty similar.
You do have a drop in February,
but that has fewer days anyway.
And July and August seem to
be tipping the scales here
with a dip in
November and in April.
So that's kind of interesting.
Could be worth exploring.
All right, maybe I'm
having too much fun,
so I'm going to keep going.
We'll do another Wildcard 3.
And for this one, I'm
interested in looking at some
of that continuous data.
So let's go ahead and bring in--
let's do date.
Let's Stick with the month.
But let's make that
continuous, I think.
And then let me change that.
Let's look at births here.
No, that's not going to work.
Let's go for-- there we
go, let's just change that.
So this is interesting because
you've got these peaks.
August, August I could
put a mark on that.
See.
Mark that, although that's
not the peak right there.
Over here is more of the peak.
So let me show that
one, so interesting.
So August, July,
OK, interesting.
Potential insight, let me do
a Wildcard 4 just for giggles.
I want to do one more with you.
And this one's
called a Cycle Chart.
So very similar to
what I did before.
But we're going to do
it a little differently.
We're going to go
and take those date.
We're going to keep the.
Discreet, and we'll do month.
And then I'll bring
date on again.
And let's keep the year.
That's good.
And then, on rows,
let's go do that rows.
See if we've got that.
Let's fit that in
the entire view.
So now, we've got those bumps.
But now, it's looking
at January and then
all the years are in there.
So that could be interesting.
One of the things
that I think is good
for a cycle chart is to
go into the Analytics pane
and bring in the average line,
and let's put it by pane.
So now, I can really--
I can see there's a
huge dip in February
in terms of those averages.
It's just a different way
of looking at the data maybe
getting some insights into
some of those averages.
OK, so now, your
final chart will
be to select one of these
ones that I've created
or that you've
created from the OG
to your wild cards all the
way to your designed one.
And you'll just lift
one of these up,
and you'll apply
design principles
to create an awesome chart.
So happy vizzing.